the reason why a country does it one way or the other
doesn't matter to the topic and
if India builds solar to
fight poverty and
promote electrification super
perfect and the reason is then
full throttle and then they build
another reason or  other countries for
another reason and that's perfectly
fine, so if we manage to
keep up this speed and this dynamic now, then we really have
a chance to turn the steering wheel.
recently we made a ranking on the podcast
about the most valuable, most
important, most relevant German
companies  have been founded since the year 2000
you have to say the
company has to be one
of the 22 most important German
companies since 2000 with the listened to
simply because it’s such a crass
story
Billions in sales probably also
worth billions an amazing
story now here live directly from the
founder personally from Stefan Müller up,
welcome to a
Müller hey Stefan yes hello thank you so
really nice to be here and as I
said in the first round I have the
name yes  I've heard
of course I snickered and then
just said let's see what happens,
but I mean you're generally or
you're all outside of your
industry very quiet,
you don't take it too seriously, you might have to
say what you actually do,
Ender  parken are companies that I
deal with large solar power plants,
so we have focused very strongly
on a very specific segment, which is
also in demand all over the world at the moment
and that is really the
development, construction and operation of large
solar power plants, what is a
large power plant I have no idea if  you see
the A7 and an A1 motorway then
you see large solar fields on the right and left
that are really more than 100 meters,
these are the things that we
build and operate, so power plant
simply means a park of solar fields
exactly, just big, there are three, as I said
different segments
one speaks of residential always the
smaller plants then there are
industrial in commercial these are the
so-called medium-sized plants where the
roofs are on plants where there are factories
or large logistics halls and then there are
the large open space plants
and that is what we do  so
old airports too so what exactly is that
really exciting for us everything that is
old conversion areas old
military sites we talk to
airport operators where it is also where it is
extremely difficult and what to
build there we will go there and
we will find that  well that's exciting and you
then produce all the
hardware yourself or you buy
one and the area is built on, so to speak, so
we develop the
project and then we buy the hardware
on the market and that changes from
time to time  very different
focus is of course still the
large solar modules come to 80 90
percent from Asia that is also an issue
but on the whole we develop
the projects we build
the projects buy the products and
then operate them and we are the
owners and we market them  the electricity
so how exactly does it work then
we always have to understand first
what I also found exciting for me in
the preparation I asked myself
how much electricity actually comes out of you
in total that is probably
I need an important key figure besides
how much  Electricity comes out and I can
hardly grasp kilowatt megawatt things
because I'm not from the industry and
then I asked my brother-in-law
who worked in the industry for a long time that
's like several tower power plants
what you release that's exactly right
so we have a total of at the moment  a
stock of three gigawatts that sounds like
something at first but
you can compare that with nuclear power plants
that are no longer running
exactly but that might be another
very good example we
can with the electricity we
generate annually about 1
Yes, we supply millions of households, or we
just did a bit of math in the VDI.
Is there actually a
problem if there are now another
million vehicles that
are electrically operated, then the
answer is no, that's not a problem, that's just
what we produce, so we
can  so much electricity passes through that a
million electric vehicles can
easily drive an average of 20,000 kilometers a year
so in
summary electricity is there and electricity
is also available we just have to
ensure that more and more solar systems and
wind turbines are built that's
actually the issue for you how many
percent  is solar and is also winter
we only do solar so we
said from the beginning focus focus
focus and we also invest in
a startup here and there and
then always say look me to the left
and look me to the right asks you where is the
right place  you're good and where you
're really good stay there and
concentrate on that and
we've done that and meanwhile we
can say a few key data that about
500 people which seems very little to me
for the outfit and you can also
after you do over  a billion
sales now with 500 people that
's really crazy yes I would
say sales per employee is
not bad you can compare it well
with other large corporations
but we try
to focus really hard
digitization is a totally mega
topic for us  uh, and there you can
do a lot, so we build
incredibly fast, we need an
incredible amount and are making
very good progress with it and just have
a cool team, I would say,
how did you get into the industry,
so let’s start now  after
roughly understanding what is now but
currently there is an anecdote that
you yourself were somehow traveling in Africa
as a student pick us up so
what do you have behind it but businessman
no I'm also an engineer and I was
still studying at the Lübeck University of Applied Sciences at the time
and  there was solar technology and
that was, huh, something very special,
a bit crazy, and then I was
in Africa and then lived in Namibia for a year
and
designed and built solar systems, either voluntarily
or at that time it was a real job, so I
then did another internship  then I
wrote my diploma thesis and worked downstairs
for a local German company it was such
a mixture and was the knowledge
also ideology or or yes I
always wanted to somehow make the world a little bit
better and save it a little bit
that was my thing, he always said
boy  do something real
yes and then afterwards he was on the
supervisory board at enapark AG so it
somehow worked out but it means
studying in that area on the way
and then starting a career in
the area of ​​Africa first projects and
then how come it happened  when it was
founded and then it really just went
from one company to another, so
I worked for BP Solar for over 10 years,
it was really the BP
Group, one of the leaders in the
solar sector, so it was actually oil,
but they noticed relatively quickly
that something was going on  and now
they're really big again and
just imagine going in and out a bit
like that, yes, and then I
ended up with the community and konichi
was like the nucleus of the
companies in the solar sector, you have to
say the Internet of things, exactly
I think that's what this
feeling was like and they really
looked for people who wanted to make
decisions, they
are entrepreneur types and
that's when I really grew up,
but I've been traveling in Asia for five or
six years,
the difference in countries is Korea Singapore
already built right there everything was already
done with solar and for
the last 25 years I have really
done nothing but photovoltaics in
different areas also
private systems and so on and by
and large it was always photovoltaics that
was always the topic but they
can do it  the German
success story
worked out didn’t work out and that
brings us back to the word focus and
that’s how we ended up when we
founded the company and I was
in Singapore at the time
he made a business plan and the
focus was really very clearly in the
foreground and so we
then built it up without the company, which means
you ended up leaving because it
was no longer relevant, so to speak,
then it’s my chance now
yes  that was the impulse and I was
always kind of an entrepreneurial type and
then it was clear that we are
now the founders three
main reasons but there were still
definitely 10 20 people who are still with
us, in the founding phase, so to speak
were there and we
really got a big whiteboard
Bottle of wine and based on how things are going then
and now we also write down from the startup
what went well what I
didn’t go well and then we
noticed relatively quickly, as I said, that we are
concentrating  on what you are really
really good at and that was back then he
will the look man solar should
actually let it work because
focus fully on it exactly and of
course we must say
benefited from it as sad as it sounds that
they could then broke  because
of course there were really really good people there
and they were
suddenly in the industry, which means we
could call a big manufacturer
in China where one of our
former colleagues was then CEO, or
we could call the inverter office
or the technical manager
and us  well known and so
in the end we were able
to build the first big projects at all but
you also didn’t have to
take up financing or something like that at the very beginning with an
investor, but that’s
sometimes the way it is and so startup
After
half a year we realized that it did
n't suit us at all and then
we had the courage
to take our own money or
one of our partners had something and who
had to borrow it and we
bought back the shares  and then we
started everything from scratch, which means
and to this day there are no
investors, just the three of us
and I, we are the owners, we are
the founders and the company belongs to us, it
's amazing the
value that has been created
Speaking of sales I think you
control it on mine yes I think that in
some years it
is really profitable other years
you could see it is less because of that
well we have actually been profitable the
whole time that makes me laugh at most
when  If you look at the balance sheet,
it is always a little difficult to
evaluate because we are also the
owners of the solar parks, that
means if a solar park
gets financing, for example, then this
financing is considered a loan
even though it is based on the project
in which  Sometimes you ca
n't see that enough in the balance sheet, so we've
actually been profitable since day 1 and that's how
we've continued. We
didn't actually trim the whole company
for sales or anything
like that, but only for cash flow that
was one of those lessons  learned from the
different companies where we
were pay attention to what money
gets in and what goes out that's
actually the great art Sales
always played of course but it's important
that you always have more money in the
account than the money goes out and what does
an industry like that have for  Yields How do
I have to explain it is very
different with us, what with us, er,
is that we cover everything in this
economic chain of solar power plants,
maybe
two or three other companies in the world do that, so
we develop the projects ourselves, we
also build them physically  We have
30 RAM machines, we have ten cranes,
we have five trucks, we have cable
milling, everything, so a few fitters, a few
assembly teams, then we plan the
system ourselves, we do all the
purchasing, we operate it and we generate
energy, there
are actually
four different ones out there  Business units and
we put them in a stew and
that way you can actually generate sales in every
value chain, of course,
and also win and
that in total is of course the
exciting and the interesting thing is once
the system is up and producing
electricity then you actually have it  every year
the more you are part of it, of course,
the basic energy gain more
what does the maintenance cost and if
you also do the maintenance yourself
you can save even more money so 20%
in it yes yes
as I said you already have a
few  Things said we like to fly
under the radar that's really our
credoor we noticed today we
all come from big companies and you
can just tell how great the pressure is
just to tell the market value and the
market value you hear on two pages
of course about profit and sales  but
on the other hand also for the grand valium
and that was just really exhausting
and we said that we do
n't do that we just don't want to do that
but if we are good then people
in the industry will know us and as you just
said in the
We're hardly known in the industry outside of us and
it's a cool feeling how did
it still run up so you
made the first system when he
said we'll do it ourselves
then where was it here in georgswerter
just around the corner so the old mountain
of rubbish from  georgswerda where the
wind turbine is on it there is a
PV system that we built, so
Hamburg exactly
we have of course the very first one was
somewhere else but that was the
the nucleus the start of the Ender Park and
I also remember how we
Hamburg  energy and
said yes, why can you
provide guarantees and why, no, we
're wrong and then they
called and realized why, okay, the
guys know exactly what they're doing and
didn't check the company, but
rather us, and that was for them  simply the
decisive point and that was our
door opener
thousands of such plants exactly yes we
now have a total of relevant
plants like 500 to 600 plants but
of course we have already built a lot more
so at the beginning we built a lot for
external parties as a general contractor
and are currently building  we are increasing for
ourselves and that is changing
again because the demand is so high, so
large corporations who
want to have their CO2 footprint down to zero are now
not only buying green
electricity, but saying okay to be
authentic and honest  to be I
also have to own the system and I have to
hold it in my hands and that's what
companies like Ikea do, for example, yes, and that's a
major project we're doing with them all over the world wherever they have a market,
so they pull the horse from behind to
look at you  look at what is our CO2
footprint in France and then
calculate how many
solar systems it is then you can develop us and
we build and operate them
as if they were ours, although it
actually becomes IKEA and the
very first this this
no that  was, funnily enough, for Hamburg
Energie and it is still
operated by Hamburg Energie and, so to speak,
the dnset, as they say, and the
electricity that belongs to them, but that was the
war, so to speak, the
money
started, that's exactly where we
really worked as a service provider
the first ones also earned the first money
and noticed hey, that's kind of
interesting for us too and then we
built our first plants with the first money we earned, so to speak, but
everything here in Germany, too,
now the East has actually
developed very, very well  Saxony-Anhalt
Thuringia so the corner that was of course
also due to the fact that the areas there
were rather cheaper you have to say that
the networks were more developed there
than an incredible amount was invested
and what you also have to say in the corner
is of course there are of course an incredible
number  Commercial areas were created, so
blooming landscapes keyword and what
was everything that didn't happen like that,
um, and then we went in and the
other thing that was exciting was we
took over an incredible number of old military airports, which we then leased and
bought in some cases,
not saying much about Apple  and an egg
because then of course there is also kerosene
and bombs and what I have lying around, that
means they have to empty it first
and that's quite real money okay but
in the end it's a huge area
somewhere in the east of the old airport and
it doesn't cost 20  Euro
square meters like a normal
commercial area, but two more like that,
but the area is of course huge
and we then
built huge solar systems on it and
if you generate the electricity there, you can
also transport it to Schweinen and
transport it within Germany
Is there such a so-called
balancing group or a
connection between Germany,
Austria, Switzerland, that's a network and
there are also individual networks to Poland,
over to Denmark and to
France, but the interesting thing was
of course that these commercial areas or
the old military areas were
usually there  also had a great mains connection
because of course they also needed a lot of energy,
that means we
first had to clear away the ordnance that was the
biggest and then
we saw a cable and then we
went and started building and these are
our systems that we operate  then
some people who also do the maintenance
everything is monitored remotely from Hamburg
we have developed our own software
for us where we
can see where it is we fly over it with our own
drones and can see if
a module is not working that goes in  in
our maintenance system that is an
electronic transmission to the service
man who is on site who gets a ping
and says here we are driving another
Hardenberg inverter flashes and
then he drives off
so why don't all the electrons do it
anymore so you can also hear the
genesis then  one would say it's
not Google where someone somehow
invented a search engine and then
immediately had an inevitable monopoly because
that was the best search and then
I feel there could have been a lot more
of this film there are two
points that are a bit against it
say that anyone can do it
point one is an unbelievable dynamic
in this market,
large corporations are very very
well like energy suppliers are very good when it comes
to long-term project development, they
know that from coal-fired power plants
and nuclear power plants, which means that
very strong offshore wind energy goes into it
are long-term plans,
you also have to invest a lot of money at the beginning and we did
n't have that, so
we decided on solar because
the development times are very short and
you have to be very quick, so
the big energy suppliers are hardly ever in this market or power plants
represented yes
and that's actually one of the
main points and I think that's also
our strength that we have
others can still do it purely
theoretically yes some have
done it but maybe not that big
and maybe you haven't either  we
had this entrepreneurial spirit as
we did and we also had the courage
this is not our company is also
our money and we really always
thought about where do we do it and where do
n't we do it and we simply decided based on our
experience and
we did  we were also active in countries
where you might
not be able to go where others might not, but where you
know that you can make quite good money,
so we
built many power plants in Jordan, in Kazakhstan, a
huge one of 100 megabytes, one of the
largest in all of Asia that really  that
's what we did a lot of
service providers for others exactly that
service provider where we earn our money
or can you earn very good money
and we put that back into
our own parks and so
it always went back and forth
and the other  which is also not entirely
untrivial, just when you
have these systems on your balance sheet, a
bit financially, because they are
seen as assets and that is
what energy suppliers don’t
necessarily like, yes, and other companies too,
that’s a real
effort  we are also we are an AG
but that's how it developed in the end
we don't have any
freely tradable shares, so we have them
and that means we have more
disclosure requirements, which
is so bad personally, but you're
also taken more seriously by the banks,
yeah  that's fun too and
that's good okay, but what does that mean,
a lot of what you've developed
has obviously been financed by the
banks, so the
real estate business is also right, so in the
end, if we're looking for a project like this,
then we're looking for a developer
Lateral entrants who come from the
real estate sector do
n't do anything else, so they look for a
piece of land, then maybe they go to
an architect and say I can
build something, he has an idea
and then it's built and then you go
to a bank and ask for one
Project financing and that's what I
said to Elektron when you see our balance sheet
then you have to know what our
business model is like and then you can
also evaluate how successful the
memory actually is and
you already have your two partners, so
to speak, from the first company from your
studies  or where is where exactly
Christa I've known him since my first
job when he was a student with me then
he was my boss in between then
I was his boss again and
we just brought Frank in later and
he's very, very experienced  has
already set up two stock
corporations and we got to
know him by chance and at
some point our eyes looked and
said we are very different
types and I always say that when
I talk to young companies, so that’s
fine if you have three  Buddies
a company measure then you have
the same opinion three times that not good and
tell me from these 1.2 years turnover is
then how many of it is
your own asset business so to speak and how
many agency or or so
this this number 1,  2, you can
make them bigger or smaller, no,
depending on how you consolidate the organization and the company, so to speak,
if you
look at our energy trading, the
turnover might be 2 billion, but if you
look at the consolidated AG, then
it's only 500 million, I'll say it that way
because we have different
companies that
handle different projects and of course our
own organization in France, our
own Spain GmbH in
Spain or Private Limited if you
put them together then you get
roughly this value okay,
so it's crazy that
something like this is possible  was and then it was
somehow
sustained because it was also, I
think at the beginning, a bit
different from today's regulations,
so you've experienced so many different
waves, describe a bit
about it, well at the beginning and when I got
my first solar system  ever
built there I still got a
feed-in tariff of two Deutschmarks
per kilowatt hour, i.e. 1 €
absolute madness I would never have
thought that we would get there in
the industry but now at some point
there was a feed-in tariff that
is then more and more  went down
every quarter and actually this
kilowatt hour that I generate is
counted and I get money for it and
you get the money, so to speak, from all electricity
payers via the Federal Network Agency
in such a pot then, so
to speak, collected that is the
pot of the Renewable Energy Act and
finally  always and that is of course
then divided by that consumed
kilowatt hour and that is what until
recently was on your bill at the bottom of
the kilowatt hour price plus
extra allowance
and we still have old systems
that are still running and will
soon run out then there  there was
nothing more to do with this EC allowance for
you, so to speak,
one always talks about electricity
production costs, i.e. how expensive is a
kilowatt hour that I
can generate with a solar system and they were
of course very high at the beginning,
just like I said, this 1 euro and there it
is  you just made a political decision
and said we want to
continue to promote solar energy, we
want to become energy independent, there was
n’t anything geopolitical here yet
and then in the
end this EG the EG law
came into being, it
went down further and further and now it’s
like that  that we don't actually use it any more,
even private individuals when they
build their solar system on the roof are
more concerned about their own
power supply their own
power supply, that means nobody
actually wants to feed it in anymore, they only want
to use it themselves because the delta
between the costs I
have with the energy supplier and those  The ones I
produce myself is of course
incredibly large, which means that the goal
today when you
build a private system is to build the system in such a way
that it suits you. It used to be
a pure investment model
more because they tell you customers or
resources otherwise
procure, so to speak, that you would otherwise no, that's we
know each other very well, we keep telling
ourselves that's
really a completely different form of marketing,
the installers are different,
the products are different, yes  the
way of marketing is completely
different for us it's really like that we
now only talk to
energy consumers so we
talk tofeed house with VW with with
also with RWE Deutsche Bahn I've
read Deutsche Bahn for example so
and then we just talk  how expensive is
the megawatt hour or kilowatt hour
exactly and it is no longer a
question of them also wanting to know where the
system is because that is virtually everything there
is a meter on the system and
meters because bird feeders are like that
and in the end there is one  Balancing group and
they are billed against each other and
then that fits and, uh, and as I said,
the feed-in tariff, which is
actually used by almost nobody anymore, so back
when I was little there was a term
called the coal pfennig, so to speak, that was
also there until you
would have noticed at some point  the guys are
cheaper than electricity on the exchange and that
’s us, that means we can
actually sell our electricity quite normally
without any subsidies, we can also
just sell it on the exchange
it’s of course a risk like
selling electricity on the electricity exchange exactly on the electricity exchange  is of course also
a risk and a bank also tells itself that
prices can go up and down
last year they went
up incredibly now they're going down again
probably yes that was really crazy
what happened but that was even
if I couldn't foresee at all and
there  If the electricity prices went like this and went under the
covers, of course we
also benefited from it, but then there was or
is this excess profit tax that
also went to us and of course we had to
or are we doing the calculations
and determining it is the responsibility of the
Federal Ministry and that  we put it
neatly in the pot okay and
now it's like that in the end we um
we haven't actually
talked about being overwhelmed for five
years six years for a long time
but we really only talk
to the electricity consumers four recently
the World was also a really cool trade fair
in Essen
somehow also turned out to be super hip thousands of visitors
and it’s all about green electricity CO2
certificates where can the system be
how big is it
can i be the buyer or do i sign
an energy purchase agreement and  there are
incredibly exciting new start-up
companies that have developed there
and then you also invest there they are
yours exactly these are such small sweet
sports where we either
invest as a threesome that is sometimes what
suits us very well but sometimes also where I am
alone  or each of our partners
invests alone, so one partner has
openly invested in a small company
that is
now doing something in the private sector in the residential sector or
is not there, that's it
then, that's no longer a startup,
so it was a few years ago  That
's also crazy, for example, I never
thought that endpal would be there or there would
still be Zola and there is 1.5, I never
thought that they would get to where they
are now and that's cool, the
spans are something like that and you can still see them
I wouldn't
say that we are a traditional
business, but our business is
such that you think you know everything,
no, you don't know everything and that can
happen again, so it's
sustainable, 1.5 degrees
in the podcast that is  Yes, still new, but it
was also rated incredibly highly
because they are investors in it and that's
how it is, so to speak, everything fits like that, it
fits, everyone has, well, of the
three you called,
different concepts, one power
with the 1.5 invests yes in
Installation companies, which is actually
clever from my point of view because that is
actually the bodeleck,
so they all have really cool ideas and
then there are also companies that take care of
energy management with
battery storage, yes, or we
have a small company
next that is also based here  Hamburg near
Seevetal, which is small for us
Fun, then there are
companies that bundle energy purchase contracts
that simply stand between us
and the end consumer because the
end consumer is sometimes too small for us,
for example I'd say a
large bakery used gigawatt hours,
that's rather too small for us and
sometimes difficult to
represent contractually  and this company eco2 grow,
which bundles these contracts and
then comes to us and says I have their
contract for ten gigabyte hours and
that's cool of us again and so
something completely new is
actually developing in this market and there are
so many new ones developing  Companies that
is exciting and in which countries have
you been active yourself
but where are you with your own
so we still had a plant Australia
India all of Europe or America
and America then
kindly became too big and then we
also have very good buyers  found and
that was the Lego family and
we filled the negotiation in Legoland
and sold the company completely
because it had simply become too big
and then the American
salesman can't
explain anything about medium-sized companies, he doesn't want to
hear that and he doesn't understand it either
we had to say it ourselves
come on, Europe is so big that's actually
okay then it's for sale what
we did that was
also a company with what yes yes they
were really big and then they became
really simple  too big we did
n't make it anymore that was the
financing and also management
attention you always say no so I
felt like I was over there once a month for a
week and that was just way too much
and here in Europe business is booming
without end and we're leaving  now even
further down and trying to
get out of countries and to get even stronger in the
countries where we are now very strong,
so Australia does
Australia what historically one of the
co-founders met an Australian woman
and said he wanted to go
to Australia and then  must he have good
reasons was a woman from three years ago
and that was also one of those who
had done business down below and and we
also knew a lot of people and then
we just founded the company there
and India is something similar
I have four years in  India lived and
it was also clear to me that we
have to go there again and that is also
currently running as a very clear core point
and for us Germany France
Spain Holland India these are the
core countries where the
order is a bit exotic
So it's exotic but I'll say
something succinctly,
maybe they don't really want to save the world,
but they need electricity and if
solar is the cheapest form of
electricity generation and also the
fastest to install, it's
of course much easier to start with
a village  electrify by
saying Company X here has a
huge solar system and then that's good and
of course it works much
faster than if you
lay any cables through the desert or
want to build any large power plants
and that's actually the really, really
big market at the moment  what happens there,
of course, our own system, everything, we have our
own team, so we’ve also had 60 people
there for over 10 years and yes, what is the
current market volume in India for you,
so that’s roughly we’re
doing the last 50 million made in
India and the trend this year
probably 100 so
unbelievable speed also in the
area that's the advantage
no so we can build a big solar
question that you can see on the Autobahn
if we want we'll build that in
a week and that's a volume of
10 20 million but that  All of the
components that come from Asia are
somehow a risk that at
some point you can no longer get the whole time that you
want to build there, yes that
also happened and we
all suffered from it, also the final price
that starts it was through Corona
it was of course that the supply chains
were disrupted, then the situation
now with the geopolitical
situation
and of course we all constantly hope
that the world will remain calm everything
that has an influence on the infrastructure
or on logistics also has an
influence on us, of course  say
or the state in the end to uh it's
nice that the Europeans that I
want to present everything don't deliver the stuff anymore
well then they would
cut into their own flesh
of course they don't
exactly do that because they have such large quantities
that they  End users need it and that's
why that's good too, but there are
currently very strong efforts to bring the
energy back to
Germany and there he is right now
fully involved and a lot of
talks going on and
I think that's good, yes
I think that will happen too  that will also
happen
i think that this location
is important it has something to
do with availability with market security
also has something to do with CO2 footprint
and i would say everyone talks about ISG
and and large corporations have to have to
of course also tracking everything that is
mental, social and governance in Enderman
has to do with transparency and
of course Europe then also plays a
bigger role, so I
think that will happen and we are
already realizing that
large companies are using green electricity here
buy unless you say but get the
module and are willing to pay more
but if you have discussions so you are considering
or at or then you are
someone who is called we
are on the customer side then no so
it will certainly be with other
people  talks were held with large investors
who in turn talk to us
and say you could explain the market to us
how do you think the
market in Germany will be in the next
ten years Stefan who are the players and
what will happen and
we very often have such discussions  Association level also
in the VDI, so here are the topics that are where
we are also involved
where we and that suits us
stay a bit in the background but
like to explain how the market
works and how many films in the
world there are in terms of size  or
from where within this model
are similar uh let it maybe
be a handful maybe a bit
more
in the USA then not even so
there are also corporations like for example
at Weiber is also they then have their
own department like at Reh  in
the yba area, however, these have been active
in the solar sector for over 10 15 years,
also in winter and their uh so
solar fun so also very strong what do
we still have in july also a well-known company
that now belongs to MVV for
energy suppliers Mannheim but the
large corporations that are coming  now right and
left and step on the gas and that's the world
without it that's
ETF from France that's RWE who
invest very heavily,
as I said, I think they have to
adapt a bit to this dynamic market situation because solar is
not wind are two different things
what is the biggest difference between
so time time factor so become insular
the decision will be made much much
faster Field that means
development times for example with
offshore wind with systems that
are on the water easily three four five six
years so wind turbines exactly so with
onschow wind I would  let's say two
to three years and with us it can
all happen in one year but in the
end you get the
same amount of energy out of one kilometer of land from an area
yes but of course you can't
set up your wind turbine everywhere and
we can't install it everywhere either
build our solar system, for example, on
agricultural land there is a qualification
among each other, that means high-quality
we are not allowed to put it on it and there has been
a regulation for several
years that preferred areas for solar are released on the right and left of the motorway
or on railway lines,
that means when  if we talk to the
owner then we can go to
one with a building permit that
is easier to build a plant there and
that's why it might be the case
at the moment when you're
traveling around the world in Germany that
somehow so many
solar systems are being built all of a sudden but that's
only  so that something to do from a railway
or a motorway in the
preferred areas are but there are
still many commission areas as I said
we have also done a very special project with the railway that's
just said
where we feed into their own
network that sounds like it
it's normal at first but not because the
Deutsche Bahn has a completely different network
than what we know, so our
network has 50 hearts and runs on one
determination and the railway network has 16 two-
thirds hearts, which means I ca
n't just use the inverter there
dock and feed the electricity that does
n't fit, yes, and that means you have to
develop special inverters,
special transformer stations, and then feed them into their
grid, and we've
done that twice now with the train, and
that's exciting when I'm always into it on the
trains  this train runs
with green electricity then it's you then it's
us partly but they
also buy the electricity on the exchange
so
it's so that you
can buy electricity quite normally on the electricity exchange you can
also buy green
electricity in Germany are currently eco
and sustainable so I think
last year I would say 40 50
percent we are already that
means the 80 percent that we
somehow want to achieve two 30
we will manage that then I'm
not worried at all no matter how many
heat pumps there are now  to be built
or how many electric vehicles are still to
come, so I'm totally
optimistic that we can manage that again
in Germany, okay, and that's
private economic, so that's from
the start-up into adults, we can
now with you, but there aren't any more
companies, the first are corporations  that you meet, oh yes, I mean,
entpal was also created that way
as a small company, you have to
say, and and 1.5
level, no, not that, but they will
get there, I believe that
their work and well, I think that
is still the case  There are companies that
become so-called unicorns that
are always in the renewable energy sector that
will still happen yes and uh but
that's from your generation there's only
you currently I would say yes it's
crazy but that was done so much
and if the energy back then than them  that
broke a lot
happened but nothing has not
much on the size then obviously
no no that's true but as I said it's
to be in the right place with the right people
with a bit of luck and we have the
company for a while  Founded in 2009 during the financial crisis,
you could have said,
oh God, that's kind
of crazy, but in retrospect
I have to say it was great because we
were then able to negotiate with the
entrepreneur who supplied us with office tables,
of course, and we can say here
we can do it in a year  he
was happy that he had a deal at all
and that was of course
impossible when we got married a few years ago,
you can only get a table if you
pay in advance so simply put, but tell me,
RWE or
other large corporations come along from time to time or wait  the
famous private equitys and say
nicely that he built there last
then somehow 14 years we give you
now
yes come hope but are you not
interested yes that is the question of whether you
want that and they and of course you have to
think a bit
doing that fits into our structure,
into our strategy, but also how is
the world developing out there, so
I would never rule that out, but
at the moment we are totally happy with the
way we work, but of course you
talk to them all the time
Of course there are offers and I mean
the value of the company I can only
judge
the whole system is it
worth a factor of 10 or something like that I would say
exciting
an evaluation so of course it will be
totally crazy about Iran and of course that
is one too  a mirror
in the morning and says awesome great but
it's so that I'm not
looking at the one you mentioned
somewhere in the account but
you want to get
then at the end of this time you would
see what we have to pay back to schools
and so on  but
I wouldn't hang that so high,
it's just really that it
's incredibly exciting to
be part of this world where we
are right now in this energy transition and how to
have a relevant relevant part
and that's a great feeling but
still  Is that what you always think or what you
hear a lot,
I suppose take a little more chips
off the table and take a little less risk
and stuff like that, but you've
probably already talked about the
selling USA and about the results
of the last few years  you've already
said so independently what should I do
with all that extra stuff, yes, but
this, what you said, one
tries to concentrate on it,
but of course we're giving
incredible speed, we're still making an
incredible development, we're looking into
this topic  energy storage just
right built the first system here
please these are all super
exciting tasks we just sat together for three and
four hours yesterday with our head of
innovation and we
thought about new ideas what else
is on the table for us well so this
topic is grid  also, for example, that the
electric cars will eventually become part of the
infrastructure, they are just standing around stupidly at the moment
and do nothing, so you
charge them, you just need them if
you have a horse, but why not
use these stores, yes, and that is
very interesting if you
have an electric car  and then I go to
our office and then
the app comes up and tells me do you want to
earn 10 euros today because the system knows
that we might
have negative or positive electricity prices
around midday because there
might be too much sun and  then
a car always uses memory, loads it
fully and loads it
back into the network for an hour and then
I can earn money and these are
all so completely new topics where you
have to think laterally how it
can work the entire
energy network is changing  right now radical
and so many new ideas are emerging
so I bet with you if we
were sitting in 5 years I would
tell you something completely different again but
our strength is that we are also
concentrating on our core competence we
look right left but only what directly
we don't look into the
wind, for example, that doesn't fit because it's
really something else, but if you
look at solar energy, so to speak, or look at energy in general,
that you're looking and, thank God, I've had it
for a few months
somehow  in view since this podcast
back then
we have had 1.5 degrees here now we
have not had endpal here sola
but at least i have
heard of them there are other companies both
you have to see them
recently for example marvel fusion  there was
a recording with Heike who
does something completely different, so
to speak, is that what is that
then that is
probably super far away yes to
say very clearly so we have to
make sure that we pay the salaries
of 500 people every month like that
means we see how we develop
new things, of course, try things
out, we're still going into hydrogen,
the first pilot projects are running
and when we have a proof of
concept like that, we go out
and say sola with electrolysers
and hydrogen buyers, we can do that
offer rather no idea
or BMW or whatever that is
actually that the cool thing is that we
can also try things out because the
systems also belong to us or we
fly over our drones, for example,
our solar system with drones permanently they
have infrared chambers then we have
a company in America  seitmark is the name of the one
that makes an image recognition and
can use the
color pattern of this infrared film to
recognize which errors are super
exciting yes and at the same time I can then also
make an assessment of how
important this error is maybe
that I have to solve it immediately or first
in a week it's all totally
new ideas that are coming up everything that
has to do with artificial intelligence with energy management that
's actually the bigger one
my buddy Alexander Graf
who makes the podcast energiezone is called the
energy zone checkout zone there's
always  Uwe Petersen from GP Joel is also
super
relevant, he does the right thing, so he
really looks to the right and left, he
does a lot with hydrogen everything
in Schleswig-Holstein, he knows the gold
and the world also had the first
hydrogen train, so to speak, supported
gas stations  we
always meet and now
the big Intersolar is again in Munich the week after next and that’s where
you meet
and you actually know
each other but there’s
a new
gold-rush atmosphere there so there should be
a lot more going on yes that’s happening
right now we have the
idea of ​​building more than 200 gigabytes by 2030 by 2030,
that
means we actually have to build 20 gigabytes
a year and we
built two gigabytes two years ago, so in the
We are now at 7 in the industry, yes it
will probably be at 10 and so
on, so this is an unbelievable
market that is emerging and now a
great many foreign investors are coming,
including large energy suppliers from England
France who are now building their own teams
and that is for  Of course it's
also a challenge for us because
I think we're a cool company and we
have cool people, but it's
really hard to find really good engineers and
that means they compete with you
and and yes, exactly, or I'll put it
that way, we're fighting over each other  the same
people as I say and then
the question is who does he decide for
because the market will eventually finally because
all the energy that is
queried is then somehow
produced yes I think it's an
exciting question and I was involved  I
also talked to Mario from Empire
because they can calculate relatively well
how many houses
are equipped with solar and if you can divide that between
the five relevant companies
then you arrive at a value
and actually know where you will be in three
years and then  five over exactly
but of course it's not over
because the topic of electric angles
comes up, uh, electric cars, the topic of heat pumps
is mega hot, everything runs on electricity and
that's where the 1.5 and Zola go in
this market 3 because they just say okay
that  needs an entire
energy supply, so he
might even need the charging station from me, the
electric car, which is ordered online,
plus the heat pump and so on, and that's
why we're on the way to
electrifying the economy, it's called
simply burning away from gas
or something  or oil but
really you can electrify
and the house of the future and I have
one that is electric I do
n't have gas I can't give anything just
electricity and if you think it through to the end on the industrial
side yes and
on  the mobility side because the
market is far from over okay, that
means there will still be enough to come in the next few decades
exactly and
there are still very many just
such a medium-sized company is also
an exciting topic was a
bit late  10 20 years so a
bit left to the side so
everything like that I'm just saying big
cold stores big
warehouses big bakeries erm that's a
huge free roof so you can
really do a lot there so
we don't really have a problem with space
because it's still incredible  there are
a lot of conversion areas and there are
still old airports or old
military sites, okay, in the
current situation they are being renatured
or put into operation again, but if we
look at the areas that
are available, that's not really an issue, so
we'll reach 250 GBV, that's
relative  of course 2013 and then it's going to
continue and we're already talking about 1,000 gigawatts in the association and
in the mvdi what how do
we get 1000 gigawatts and
that's relaxed because when this
topic comes up hydrogen for the
chemical industry, for example for the
steel industry, then we
really talk  about a different order of magnitude, if then
Germany suddenly becomes
really competitive in the future, so people are
always worried in
Germany, even now, because of the
increased energy costs and so on and
then there are other people saying,
well, everything is only temporary, Germany
will make it really big  because
we are the first ones here
to obtain energy for free, namely from the sun
from the wind and otherwise
nothing would cost anything more so supposedly
or little and then we have for our
entire chemical parks and for everything is
nations, I believe that too, namely
Quite simply,
we are
currently not comparing the
production costs in politics with the prices
the end customer has, so in France, for
example, there is an industry price, an
electricity price for industry that is
fixed, but it is artificially
subsidized, yes, that means something
additional  Costs now still come to
estimate and set the whole nuclear power course and to
renew them or build new ones that costs
billions and if you calculate it properly
then it is not a
cheap price and David Germany will certainly be there
in the next few
years  everyone always shakes their heads
supposedly I don't think everyone who is
familiar with the energy system knows that
2030 is and then let's have a look and then
we'll have a look
at the market again and that will be
super exciting you were
a discussion for Germany  that's what many
American
investors say, too, or as they always say, a digital
mastermind up to Bill Gates Bill
girly, so you need
it now with the micro Milan,
you see, I don't think
nuclear power is the most expensive form of
energy there is  is purely
physical if I do the math,
so to put it bluntly, a nuclear power plant
is not insurable Point why if
you are insurable because if the
damage occurs then it is too expensive
this Fukushima story alone
cost over 400 billion dollars
yes and that  It's not over for a long time,
we don't have a repository, the electricity
costs aren't just
these uranium things and so on, so that's it, there
's a lot more to it than that
otherwise
we won't get any financing
for nuclear power, so no one asks
this political question that's
always there outside, do you want nuclear power yes
or no, that's a question that's
of course very politicized, but if you
asked then you're responsible for the fact
that it's a repository for you  the corner does
n't come, no, of course, then the
question is different again, instead of
solar power with 5-6 cents per
kilowatt hour in Germany, you might want
to pay double, triple or quadruple the price just because it
comes from the small one, no, well, I
think the way is predetermined  what
are the arguments by by by Bill
Gates and cool that's so important
is yes I think I
sometimes don't understand it to be honest so
honestly if we still
come up with the idea of ​​somehow building small handball
big nuclear power plants
honestly the  I don't want to have it in my
basement or in the garden,
from my point of view it's completely the wrong way,
but there are different ones, I
studied physics or I know
all the technology, I'm deep in there, I think
I can rate it quite well, but it
's energy  was always political yes always
and that this whole discussion that we are
having now and I think
also have that you are
talking openly and honestly about it again
that maybe the rapprochement with
Russia was completely wrong yes
we have established everything but these are the
the same people who suddenly
say let's act in North Africa
build solar systems and
produce hydrogen and pump it over here
then in 10 years we'll have the same
issue we have to become independent
independent also means independent of
uranium we currently have 20% from
Russia 60%  from the Urals is
processed by rosatatom, it's all
political and that's why I think it
lets use the energy that's easy here for
free and that's so close
Geothermal energy there are many other
dates
is totally exciting and I also think
that it works well  and we can
become independent we
don't need any additional options from the outside
if we think European is great
of course we produce almost
twice the amount of electricity
plant in Spain yes you can also
combine well you can make your own network
you can feed distributed in Europe
super super  and is it all happening fast
enough now that
climate change is happening this summer and
something is still within reach in contrast so we are
now on the right track I'll put it that way
I'm really optimistic
there was also this
pv strategy days recently from  from the bmwk from the
Federal Ministry with Harbeck it was
actually the first time in 10 15
years and someone
asked her where are
the modex actually yes and you don’t need
a solar industry or need
research but where are the
Borderlands and if I do  the
bottom line is that there are 17 forms
for 17 different network operators
who sometimes want five pages from us
and sometimes one page it takes forever
yes or to submit a building permit for a
solar system that
is totally standardized in what I would call a
small community in the south  from Cottbus, where
there may only be one or two people in the building authority
and one
may have a corona virus and the
other is our problem, these are
really tangible issues and not this
overarching
issue, where do we get the
solar modules from now, we'll solve that  yes, but
everything that is local at the local
decision-maker level, we need
help and this is the first time
we have hoped that this is
going the right way that we can
move forward and the same thing
is happening now with wind and the same thing is
happening  with other forms of energy where you
just ask, okay, give us the top
ten list, they're going to really get to the point
and that they'll work them off
and that looks very good at the moment,
yes, I mainly have that kind of thing,
it's no longer there, that was one of the
big proponents  I have to see how
the new one is,
so it was demolished,
so it was
still very easy to do,
so it was one of the most renowned
experts in the field of renewables, so
you say it's kind of a shame is a shame, I
mean, if you make a mistake like that,
I don't want anything  to say and that
was good or bad is I think he
asks her I think myself why I
did it but it's stupid for
us
not stupid but for us as a
company but really for the entire
industry and also processed so
we have to look like them
but fortunately we have
actually worked through these issues and now we
will see what will happen in the next three
to six months and then I
think things will go really well again.
Germany is
in the top group of these
sustainable energy changes in the world, yes  I would
say they are of course I
just said India these are the
different approaches exactly and they
motivate India are electricity in the
small communities how do we get
conductors ready in America has something to do
with investment yes it's about
getting tax advantages
if you do politically what the
government would like to do and the government
is currently fully committed to renewables and that is
why there is also incredible construction,
so every country has to know its
own structure,
I think it's driven, so those who
want to invest there can still
make money and can at the moment  you can
make a lot of money with renewables, so
things will go in that direction,
so I'm optimistic, we
still have a few countries that
are maybe a little bit better, we
talk a lot about heat pumps or whether
we should change the whole system a bit
that  Denmark is certainly
one of the pioneers where everyone is kind of looking at
how they did it, actually they
just made it a bit more intelligent when
they implemented it by
balancing out bans and subsidies,
which always went well, we also have
countries like Austria, you have to say, the
Persians are already renewable  due to
strong hydropower they are already
over 80%, but we also have countries where
you don’t expect it like uh
Portugal Portugal
switched to wind and solar relatively early on and the
grid is actually okay, so it
’s a small country and they
70-80% are now renewable, so
it's really exciting what's happening in the
countries now, so if you think of
Europe, I would be independent of Russia
and all the men from classic
energy suppliers, yes, and
of course that's the goal and we'll do that
too  create no well I think
within Europe you can
bring that together super we have northern countries that are
good in wind we have geothermal
countries we have a lot of hydroelectric power in the
Alps and around the old ones
there are all sorts of renewable
forms of energy that maybe in the
future  it can also
be tidal power plants it can
be wave power plants with a lot of research
and I think the combination is exciting
there is not one solution there is only
one combined solution because we
need sun and wind for example and
if you compare them over the course of a year
then you can see  all of a
sudden there's almost a line, let
me put it that way, not
100 percent and these ominous
dark blue and I don't like the word
it's still there it's easy
to absorb with storage and if you do
hydropower and maybe even
a little with others  countries
but works together and tries to
balance that out then you really
get the beautiful beautiful man super also
industry drive
so we we have big plans at the moment
we always don’t count in the evaluation
of the company but in which how much
how much can we install how
many services  can we
now come up with a plan that we
want to get the full 30 GB by 2030 and we
currently have three
built ourselves and another one
built for others so we are now
really going full throttle yes yes we are of course
also getting interesting offers for
partnerships where  you also say okay
that might be necessary if you do
n't want to be overtaken to the right and left
and there are a
lot of people coming to the right and left just now
the big energy suppliers said
we're still the biggest in Europe
with a stock of solar systems I
'll be Roland  incredibly strong BP is
also coming in RWE is going full throttle all the
coal that they
generate somewhere else, they
could always push it in sideways, so to speak, and that's um,
you have to say, and of course we have to
ask ourselves what our strategy is, so
we want it  now we're
extremely fresh but of course you can
grow even faster but how much you
have to that's another
discussion do you still see yourself
as an impact company I mean that
sounds a bit like what
I said before  So when I started I
had the same feeling of
somehow making the world a little bit better
and that's a cool
feeling to see that I'm now being
invited to you here that's cool too
no that's yes but it's without
confirmation  if you are approached from outside
we do a lot of these
small ones if you have the fireside chat
with big companies where you have to leave your cell phone
outside of course
and then he asks her here to ask grandma
how he wouldn't normally ask it like that and
that's of course fun stuff like that  that's
that's actually the cool confirmation
and that's the impact, and
if we're negotiating energy purchase contracts with the really big
corporations
and the little enapark is sitting
next to it, that's kind of a
cool feeling when you end up doing it
like this and  I mean we're
no longer talking about the startup that
has any dreams now, but
you've really
built a relevant medium-sized company,
it's finished and now it seems to be
running very well and we're putting our
own money back into the company,
all right  Of course we have
something nice here and there, but we
really make sure that we
continue to be active in the industry and
that's only possible if you put the money back in
and we'll do that, um,
and the systems are getting bigger and more
complex there are  the first
floating systems we have
just
seen in the end or just when you
think of the people who are to
be renatured again and again, where are
large water areas that will
first be paved over with solar for 20
years and the water and the whole
environment can change  recovery can
denature it takes so long
and then it can be used again so you
can still do an incredible amount and there
are still an incredible number of new ideas
where you have to act and as
a park we can’t just
stand still, so that’s just not possible  That
means I really like going to the office in the morning
but I have new topics every morning
you want to
live here in Hamburg I was in the office every morning in Hamburg,
even during Corona I was there
and just
to continue the company and as I said I
have  now no more sleepless nights
but these are full full working hours
that we all need full commitment
and management attention and we have to
go new ways every day and
make new decisions and also not
make nice decisions what what
say my difficult decision or
difficult decision so if  you
finally withdraw from certain countries
and the question of how do
you communicate that because of course
it’s always about securing
jobs and so on and you
know, but you have to stay in this country until December 31st
to then
do the final work  how do
I get the employees somehow
pulled aside so that they say hey
people stay until the last day and
then we'll have a cool party and
then you get the envelope and everything's
fine, so these are really important
topics that you have to deal with  currently
what do you get for if we
now produce your kilowatt hour of electricity, so to speak, what is
current yes
you can really read that online
easily there are
online portals that have these energy purchase
contracts but PPS and the values ​​are right there
at the moment I would say at 8
to 11 cents it always depends a bit on the
amount and over the
period of time over the length and you
operate a solar park yourself can
produce for 6 to 7 cents I would
say okay at the moment so if you open that
German
material has cost and the rent or
lease somehow what once he buys that
's all in these seven so there's
really everything in there including service and so on that
means at the moment I can
either sell the electricity on the exchange
yes or I can just use energy
Make acceptance contracts and then
take them and they can also
be 11 12 cents and but
really classic marketing do
n’t worry, that means we have there
because they do direct business and
that but you don’t do any
marketing  We
actually hired a marketing person for the first time three or four years ago,
but
we have now also noticed that this has to
be done, of course, and it
has something to do with employer branding,
but of course it also has something to do with
this new office  we
built in HafenCity that of course
also has something to do with CI because you have to
communicate internally the employees
have to be motivated a
canteen just opened surveys done what kind of
food do you want you have
vegan only vegetarian I wanted CO2
so that’s all  Topics that actually
end up on my desk every day and they also have to be done,
but it's really right that you
make a knife appearance somehow,
measure the special team, but you do
n't place any advertising, so there's
probably no
Google ads, so there's no such thing as the
most successful  Guests probably who were
here in the podcast didn't
switch ads, yes, but we
were with you a few times and
looked at what's
available and of course we're doing it now
that we're looking at how do
we get properties so we have to
advertise  but then again that's
a kind of advertising that's totally
basic, so how do I reach a
landowner in Lower Bavaria and
you get him through the local newspaper and
not through
OMR, first of all, yes, or something else
if we're looking for craftsmen and we're
looking  Yes, simple electrical
technicians, service technicians, they are not on
LinkedIn, nothing, they even get the
Sächsische Tageblatt or something,
yes, if at all, that is really the
great art of finding people,
not in there either, so it is really
difficult, we have huge posters on
our solar systems  and
somehow said you're up
for saving the world yes then come to us
something that's quite banal and that's what
really works so really
classic marketing I'll make a big
poster of a solar system where everyone
somehow drives by tomorrow
say that can be very exciting  Saving the world
so there are totally unusual things
and of course we are now
thinking a lot more about the
positioning of the ennerpark too,
of course that is also part of it because
as we already said it is when we
sell the electricity consumers to the end customer
it is important that the
knowledge of enerpark is important and we are
now also making more press releases when
we are negotiating with VW or BMW and
then they quickly google Ender
Park and nothing appears, then they say
what is there with
the image  Advertising that we also have to do,
but we don't go to a trade fair
with a stand, for example, but we
go to the international one with over 60
people and they have a task that
has to see where the next cable
manufacturer is, what's the next,
so cut to one  Going to the trade fair
made it impossible the first time and all the cameras were
completely relaxed again, but we
think we're flying under the radar with this one, I'll
admit that it
's just fun and I think that
you called us now, I think so
too  cool, of course, and that's
also a small accolade,
I would have expected that three years ago,
maybe, but now she's here
and everything's fine, well, yes, I mean, I have to be
honest, I just did
n't understand it myself for a long time, even
though it's here in Hamburg  happened and
then I thought to myself, okay, that's
definitely somewhere else and then there are
several, that's unique, so that's
somehow not in Munich, not in
Berlin, not in Paris, you
pulled it up here in Hamburg by chance
and yes, and it's kind of like that  bit
not in the company that
can perhaps bring the future of the city with it,
so as a location if this grows here, we did
n't really think about it,
but that sounds good, for example, these are
certainly topics that
will come up to us at some point where
we  say okay let's expand yes no uh
maybe we want to
do another location okay think twice
exactly but we are already at the
limit again we actually wanted to
rent two days now we have only
rented one and I hope you dear
tenants are not listening but  it may well
be that will still be needed, but
you told me in the audition that
she is now really
asking investment banking professionals from the profile what do we do then,
well, what we do is that we
naturally develop solar systems that we
now also call that  ready
to build so ready to sell
resell so Ikea Mann example so
they would like to be the owner of the
solar system that means they tell us
what I just said France
we need so and so many megawatt
hours we calculate down means 200
megabytes of solar that we are looking for to develop
they build them and sell them
completely to IKEA and for that you need
such investment people because it’s about
financing modelling, the
evaluation er determination of such a
err power plant and for that you need real
people who are real investment bankers
so in the end they’re still process-type
and they  look at it and then there is
negotiation and then the document is missing and
so it's like selling a huge
high-rise building, the same process
and when you have people who know
we are process running, who
are somehow thinking oriented or maybe
from the release date  come then
you can use them super or keep trying
some so apply
right there Goldman or something else or
because
save the world he seems to use
okay okay so many positions open
so amazing story
I think I have understood everything now
and then  your view
of the world on the current issues,
but I am very pleased to hear that
you are optimistic, so
in conclusion that you somehow
have a positive view, at least of yes, in the
end of the climate change challenge,
yes, I think they have that
we also have to take there isn't an option
point so say we have to
work on it no matter how many people
are against it now or whatever happens and
you can definitely see demonstration
types good or bad saying we
just have to do that otherwise the
world is really screwed up and  we really
still have a chance and we
really have to take that last chance
must be
understood everywhere, no, unfortunately you don't have to
say that, but I think that the
majority, uh, has understood that and that's
consciously there, but
of course there are other opinions, you have to
also respect just talked about nuclear
energy if you would interview someone here who
would certainly take a different argument for it the
question is who will win afterwards but I
think we can still do it
but time is really running out and
but there is always that  Argument that
Germany, or even
Europe itself, is relatively small and does
n't matter in the global climate balance,
but what I always find exciting
to see is that China or
Korea has just been discussed with me that these
are countries that you don't see that way  So they
are already very, very far ahead,
actually only absolutely yes, and that is
one has to say, everything says clearly,
the nuclear power plants and
coal-fired power plants are still building, but they are one
of the biggest
drivers of the entire renewable
energy market, the whole large number of
wind turbines and PV systems  are are
mostly built in China now Korea
is well behind India happens a
lot America
that means there is already worldwide there is
the most built
as I said I think to
come back again the reason why a country
does it like that doesn't matter the climate
and if India builds solar to
fight poverty and
push electrification super
perfect and the reason is then
full throttle and then it's
another reason for us and
another reason for other countries and that's totally
fine so if we do it  If we can
keep up this speed and this dynamic now, then we really have
a chance to turn the steering wheel because
you yourself are also green become
political
entrepreneurs you could have said
something else
we also worked a lot with the center
with the other parties
now, of course,
I have a lot to say, the
political drive is, I think, an
extremely important one that we all
have to work on, but actually the
main goal has to be in the foreground and that
is of course right now in this
discussion that we are having with the
the laws and then a
party dropped out that’s always the case
I think you can do that really we
really have a different topic than your
quarter percent more or less that
might be elected here next time
okay okay so very very impressive
crass story how did  I was
n't aware of it, you hardly
ever get to see it, so you can
google a bit, but then you get
a feeling for what's going on,
thanks for the insights,
of course, congratulations on the company, I'm um, it
goes further and maybe I know
not in the next two years there will always be
an update when the thing is then
twice as big so you can do
everything, of course, super, thank you, me too,
ciao
[music]